und dass ich betrogen hat ich bin
allerdings wieder einmal vorne und wir
kamen zu ihrer beliebtesten gameshow
wasser oder wodka besorgt
es ist das neue jahr ich muss hallo
sagen haben neue fragen neue vom alkohol
zu trinken müsst ihr 18 sein
also kommt mir jetzt nicht aussah ihr
seid 16 kisten bier und wein floss
deutschen nummer anmerken oder er fragt
eine oma im supermarkt ob sie passt auch
heute es ist ein spiel für die ganze
familie alkohol ja wenn du zu viel
trinkt sind stimmt so
ja wenn du dir mit willkommen zu unserem
luftigen youtube-video wir führen vier
becher mit wodka und sechs becher mit
wasser
jeder bekommt fünf shorts und wir müssen
versuchen den anderen wie beim poker zu
täuschen
das heißt wenn man wodka was darf man
sich nicht anmerken lassen
und wenn man wasser hat dann kam ein
bisschen damit spielen und da die
meisten kurzen erraten hat der hat halt
nicht locker machen gewonnen nicht
ja also jetzt möchte ich einmal durch
kelly dreht sich irgendwann mit kelly
einmal durch ich drehe mich um und dann
verteilen wir das sei damals durchaus
wieder mehr sein können dass hier jemand
gerade eine regisseur oder produzent
schaut führen dem gerne rollen an hanni
und nanni sind wir wirklich ist es aus
angst oder ich werde richtig gut mischen
ich kannte ja wort ich habe jetzt
gewaltig allein gemacht dass sie einfach
alles komplett gleich aus wenn sie
keinen unterschied so jetzt musst du
menschen das sind kerry afghani auch
immer der erste trainer kannst du doch
mal mischen ja was machen wir hier
eigentlich jetzt plötzlich mehr
aussichtspunkte die billag ist überall
da wo mein gott für mich das heißt
theoretisch könnte jeder von uns auch
viel wodka und einfach sah man ja dieses
tape heute beide ganz schön also kelly
sagt und schlägt am blutritt aber ich
bin mir nicht so sicher ein niedriger
blutdruck ich mir noch ergänzungsmittel
gotha zu helfen
wir machen schon wer anfängt
[Musik]
durch ab durchstarten sagt es so ich
sagte vielleicht noch als fake weil ich
bewusst so was doch auslasten jetzt
glücklich mannes sabina
botta wasser das verpasst so schlecht
wenn die us-kicker ist enorm vermissen
du weißt ganz genau dass ich keine
emotionen in meinem gewicht fast weg
gegangen
das ist so nah ich bin auf jeden fall
also
wasser
[Musik]
also spiel was mich so sehr hat dieses
spiel macht mich so zu nazi das war
wasser
sie kennen und bald auch schon vor gut
wir haben uns auch voller voll oft schon
jetzt liegt er ganz ehrlich und treu
kopfball an zusagen geben monat einmal
also macht es kurz und schmerzlos
hierfür gibt es noch so für
trinksprüchen und sein so sind ein
großes
[Musik]
die kippe
[Applaus]
ich denke wichtig ist wasser das war ja
gewesen
nein ich musste man hatte mich fast
altmodische spring/summer ich dachte nur
so gemacht dass das für mich verarschen
ausatmen genau ob da ist auch einfach
wieder sei es einfacher klapphocker
liegt und schmeckt wie lange ferner ja
also es ist milliarden gesprächen wo
sollten wie solche die überhaupt fand
heraus dass ich wirklich dass er das so
wirklich nicht wirklich dass er das so
wirklich was ich kann es ja gar nicht
nachprüfen was das wissen vertrauens
zwischen uns beiden eigentlich dieses
video das wird richtige metaebene wieso
beste freundinnen vertrauenstest hat sie
das wirklich getan sternchen dollar
etwas na ja woher willst du wissen dass
es wirklich wort gar nicht was ach so
stehe es auch gar nicht hier weil wir
eine bestimmte funktion wenn du richtest
machen ob jetzt vertrauen wir nicht mehr
wie viele stücke zeigen und hasst weil
es da so weil ich ja nicht gedacht ich
vertrau dir einfach verstehst du hast
weil du hast kein punkt gemacht die
vorher habe ich alle erwarten so hat
jetzt hier werdet ihr opfer hatte sich
die schlaue des preises drei getrunken
und ich hab zwei davon der rat stimmte
und du kriegst drei punkt auf dem fall
doch du bist jetzt auf jeden fall fahren
so ist eine rate keinerlei praktische
meinverein.de oder ich habe ich einmal
getäuscht
so müssen wir die punkte ja man ich muss
doch ich muss mir noch gar nicht mehr
vergessen das war mord weil das war dein
erster wodka
das hat ja schon 2 im spiel zwar schon
getrunken und es sind noch zwei musst du
dich ja wenn ich die jetzt beide habt ja
was freust du dich so steins einig nun
machen geht es zu 24
[Musik]
nein ich hab das okay du hast nicht
sagen
ich weiß nicht ob das gar nicht
mitbekommen ich hab mich ja ich dich
auch zum rektor dass auf jeden fall
wodka willkommen beim besten spiel auf
youtube
gleichzeitig haben du bist als erster
das heißt einer von uns hat eigentlich
auf jeden fall noch ein wodka aber das
hat ja alles eigentlich gleichzeitig zu
ja nein wenn wir gleich durchdringend
weiß ich doch logik mit vanessa und
kelly
wir müssen beim classic bringt es mit
einer weißen rauch wenn ich hab's doch
mal ein wort gehabt dass meine rache
dafür dass ich dich zu nutzen gebracht
dass ich zum kotzen was dran sein kann
weil im wasser davon auf der lippe hat
ist und wenn man wasser auf deine
braucht man so also dann ist er weg
ich habe gewonnen
dann kann man sehen ob ich werde mir
hier in man kriegen kann sich auch einen
anderen tarif bei verwies wonach china
hatte maximal for you
er weiß wie viele leute mir seitdem
geschrieben haben dass die angefangen
haben diese hier mauern verbergen sind
wieder gaben gerne schön so auch keine
spiele haben wir natürlich auch ein
video gedreht und falls ihr wissen wollt
auf kanal haben wir die arbeit nieder so
jedenfalls ihr wissen wollt was es ist
wobei man vergessen dich mal wanne zu
abonnieren und bekenne ich kenne nichts
abonnieren
[Musik]
ach so eins habe ich gar nicht verraten
jetzt prangt jetzt lese ich meine bank
ich habe im fahrwasser sachen auch noch
mal worte rhein gekippt
also auf klo gegangen ist habe ich
nochmal über also ein bisschen batterien
gemacht damit alles so ein bisschen nach
wodka schmeckt aber ich hatte wirklich
das war vertrauensperson als nämlich
angefangen hat zu sagen de jetzt vor der
vertrauens tab habe ich halt gesagt was
meinst du ja wie im vertrag
da hab ich alles klar gemacht